Matt Matt Damon and I blew it
correct this is a true story and you
through roleplay made me feel better
about it rolls plays probably through an
improvised scene roleplay weird okay
that's fine
and I went up hey you office it you
Parks and Rec it to the camera yeah I'm
on show you have a little y'all
Krasinski here cuz it's creative a
little present peep okay right I'm
learning okay so Matt Damon you have to
say something in order for you to do
that I love you one because yeah I'll be
the straight man I'll be the Krasinski
right okay ready you're the Krasinski I
just have I just have the beginning of a
rash and it looks like a handprint like
someone slapped me right there
so stop me right there that's glowing is
that normal
no you're fine I also I was throwing up
earlier yeah more got stuck in my throat
I'm stuck in your throat all right well
maybe should go to a doctor's on my way
I would go to a doctor but I don't
believe in doctors alien took me when I
was a boy and he told me dr. Emil was it
a real big alien or I blew it
it's okay oh god you're just adorable no
yeah I like a big baby huh
from those too much got from airs too
much it's big game for you
we got him oh no no no no no let it go
nope weird here can we get a close-up oh
there's nothing here yeah there's
everything here there's a world here say
there's nothing here I'm not doing it I
wish I could take a picture and show you
you're taking thousands of pictures a
second Wow
Irish what does that mean I flick the
wing and there are sweat less people but
why does that make sense well did you
know this about yourself or no know that
look he'll catch up get him up by the
end of the interview let's get him up a
little bit don't chicken wing it the
whole way through the rest for interview
I think there's fun in like the office
or parks my tempo where I look at the
camera and then you ask me why I'm
looking at the camera that has that been
done oh let's see that alright so give
me a terrible joke mmm so Jim I'm having
a birthday party this weekend
the theme is nope pants what are you
doing are you mugging what are you
saying there's no pants you think mine
your pants prick don't don't I'm sorry
Tommy
oh you have a relationship with Noman
he's my guy dude just come on sit back
it's a good idea for a birthday party
you know what you're not invited you've
stopped
cameraman took his hand off the camera
this is gonna be a problem because
neither one of us is ever gonna fail in
a bit [ __ ] I hope you have a number the
every other no no all right I'm through
but here's we'll make it another bet
our hands are velcro together so we make
the sound three two ah old Val Canon
that hands real sweaty let's fill this
one dry as a bone
Razia what happened to all your sperms
in one of your testicles like
everything's dry on one side you're
bearing a once that everybody got real
fertile you look like you're super
fertile on this side of your body
sperm here sperm there like cotton candy
there doodling which do you want
look dry while I'm working under stall
sorry